a energia nuclear faz a diferença e eu
estou aqui para contar um pouco sobre
como eu descobri isso eu sou engenheira
criar formado pela universidade federal
do rio de janeiro
e quando eu era criança eu não imaginava
fazer a engenharia nuclear na verdade
esse curso nem existia na época no ac no
brasil é no ensino médio eu fiz um
técnico em informática eu fazia o
técnico de manhã o ensino médio regular
à tarde um cursinho de inglês à noite e
para conseguir o diploma do ensino
técnico é preciso estagiar e eu acabei
fazendo um estágio numa empresa nuclear
eu consigo comer é consertava os
computadores dos funcionários e isso me
levava aos escritórios que ficavam ao
redor das usinas e eu ia lá olhar aquele
prédio do reator int idéia do que tinha
ali dentro é ficava imaginando curiosa
como aquilo funcionava
nessa época eu não pensava em entrar na
área mas eu já sabia que queria ser
engenheiro porque eu tinha um desejo de
usar cálculos e físicas para resolver
problemas e quando eu vim prestar o
vestibular da ufrj tinha pouco criado o
curso de graduação em engenharia nuclear
e na hora de estudar a inscrição eu
ainda não tinha muita idéia do que era
aquela área
mas eu ainda estava curiosa na primeira
semana de aula eu me apaixonei
ao longo do curso eu descobrir que a
radiação é utilizada para diagnóstico de
doenças para tratamento de doenças como
câncer e que é utilizada para
esterilização de equipamentos médicos
como seringas que é utilizado para
esterilizar até mosquito e erradicar
doenças era utilizada em aplicações
espaciais
aquele robô curiosa que está em marte
ele é movido a bateria nuclear
ela pode ser utilizada até mesmo para
trocar a cor de uma pedra preciosa ou
para ajudar no processo de restauração
de uma pintura e eu finalmente descobriu
que tinha dentro daquele prédio e como
aquilo tudo funcionar
eu vou falar um pouco disso pra vocês
parece muito
é é bem simples o processo se o processo
de de produção de energia dentro de um
reator
vem da ficção que é o neuton que atinge
um átomo de urânio e ele se divide e
nessa divisão nessa função ele produz
outras duas partes de 2 a outra três
nêutrons e energia e esses dois a três
nêutrons bom funcionando outros átomos
de urânio e assim a reação em cadeia
essa energia ela serve para aquecer a
água que fica lá dentro do reator
aquele sistema vermelho essa água vai
aquecer uma outra água num outro sistema
que vira vapor roda a roda da turbina eo
gerador transforma essa rotação da
turbina energia que vai pra ser
distribuída para as praticadas e o que
mais importante que eu descobri é que
essa energia é uma energia limpa e ela é
parte da solução pra mudança climática
eu sei que essa provavelmente não é a
primeira associação que vem na cabeça de
vocês quando você pensa em energia
nuclear mas deveria ser porque esse
processo não produto em um gás de efeito
estufa
nada todos nós temos sentido o troar
mudanças climáticas né
a onda de calor no rio de janeiro já
teve dias com sensação térmica de 50
graus é agências e institutos
pesquisaram o que nós fazemos que causa
tanto essa liberação de gases de efeito
estufa e uma das principais razões é a
utilização de combustíveis fósseis como
carvão no mundo o carvão ainda é a fonte
de energia mais utilizada para a
produção de energia
o mundo ainda queima muito carvão para
produzir energia na frança fase de crise
hídrica nos níveis dos nossos
reservatórios de água estavam a níveis
críticos é o brasil colocou suas
termelétricas a combustíveis fósseis a
todo vapor para suprir a demanda de
energia
além disso o consumo de energia
tende a aumentar ele é um índice de
disponibilidade de serviços básicos da
sociedade como tratamento de resíduos
com o tratamento de esgoto hospitais ou
seja com o consumo de energia está
diretamente ligada ao índice
desenvolvimento de um país e nós
dificilmente vamos ficar sem carregar
nosso celular sem usar o microondas
geladeira televisão aquecedor o ar
condicionado no caso do rio de janeiro
então o que o mundo vai fazer precisam
de mais energia queimar mais carvão
a solução ideal é optar por energias
limpas o que inclui as renováveis e
nuclear
eu sei que muitos podem pensar que o
brasil ser um país tropical nós podemos
ficar só com a solar eólica e eu
acredito que elas são parte da solução
também mas essas duas energias
elas são intermitentes elas dependem do
tempo para produzir num dia nublado
chuvoso a solar não vai produzir tanta
energia num com muito vento ou com pouco
vento porque a eólica ela funciona numa
variação de ver e específica de vento
então se tiver muito ou muito pouco a
eólica também não vai produzir tanta
energia já nuclear ela vai produzir 24
horas por dia sete dias por semana ela
energia confiável de base
você sabe exatamente quanto ela vai
produzir em quanto tempo
além de tudo isso ela tem
ae antes é esse é um gráfico sobre as
emissões de gases de efeito estufa na
nas diferentes tipos de energia
se você contar o ciclo todo aí você
conta criação do combustível da do
transporte por caminhões da manutenção
de geradores a diesel nuclear então você
vê sim uma pequena parcela uma pequena
produção desses gases de efeito estufa
mas comparada às outras fontes segundo
pesquisas a nuclear produz até - que é
solar e ela tem uma grande densidade
energética uma pastilha de urânio de 7
gramas
2 a mesma quantidade de energia que
cerca de 800 quilos de carvão e uma
usina nuclear
ela ocupa um espaço em média cem vezes
maior do que uma central energética
solar 100 vezes menor desculpa do que
uma central energética solar precisa
para produzir a mesma quantidade de
energia
atualmente a energia nuclear é co
responsável por 10% da produção do mundo
né de energia no mundo e esse número vai
aumentar porque existem dezenas de
usinas assim construção sou na china são
mais de 20
a frança tem mais de 70 por cento da sua
energia baseada nuclear
são mais de 50 usinas nos estados unidos
são apenas 99 no brasil nós temos do
atualmente em operação
anualmente a energia nuclear evita a
emissão de cerca de 2 bilhões de
toneladas de dióxido de carbono na
atmosfera
imagina se nós trocássemos as pontes até
as combustível fóssil nessa fonte
energética a combustível fóssil por
nuclear
uma pesquisa feita pela nasa e pela
universidade de columbia em nova york em
2013 chegou à conclusão de que cerca de
1 milhão e 800 mil pessoas deixaram de
morrer por poluição do ar porque nós
utilizamos energia nuclear nuclear salva
vidas o que aliás foi o título do meu
vídeo quando eu apliquei paraolimpíada
mundial nuclear
ano passado eu escolhi na no vídeo falar
sobre aplicações médicas é porque minha
vó passava por um tratamento de câncer e
ela passava por esse tratamento de
radioterapia
mas antes de falar sobre a olimpíada que
ele ia contar pra vocês como eu cheguei
até lá né
é eu comecei a minha graduação em 2011 e
na minha turma entraram cerca de 25 24
alunos três meninas desde o início da
graduação eu me envolvi em todas as
coisas possíveis na primeira semana de
aula e foi conversar com o professor
para entender mais sobre a
área e ele me ofereceu uma vaga no
laboratório dele e assim que ele pode me
deu uma bolsa de iniciação científica e
eu finalmente comecei a utilizar os
cálculos pra pesquisar sobre os reatores
nucleares
é também no primeiro ano ouvindo uma
palestra de um pesquisador de uma
universidade é do do laboratório nos
estados unidos em um grid no tennessee
ele ofereceu para conversar melhor com
os alunos de doutorado pra fazer um
convênio compartilhar pesquisas e eu no
auge do meu primeiro período de
graduação
fui falar com ele que eu queria depois
de muito esforço
meu e principalmente dele para convencer
o pessoal do laboratório é eu consegui
um estágio de dois meses e foi minha
primeira viagem ao exterior
nesses dois meses eu desenvolvi um
software utiliza este conhecimento do
meu técnico é uma interface gráfica um
banco de dados nuclear que foi submetido
e adicionado ao banco de dados do centro
computacional de informação de segurança
radiológica dos estados unidos é eu
participei organizei visitas técnicas
onde eu finalmente entrei naquele prédio
misterioso no início pra mim do reator
em 2014 eu participei do programa
ciência sem fronteiras e fiquei um ano
estudando nos estados unidos o que aliás
era um sonho de criança eu tinha até
considerado ser babá nos estados unidos
um tempo para tentar realizar mas deus é
muito perfeito e quando eu consegui
realizar esse sonho ele veio da da
melhor maneira possível
durante esse um ano eu e mais dois
amigos da universidade
conseguimos estagiar numa das maiores
empresas nucleares do mundo que tem sede
nos estados unidos
e eu atualmente estágio nessa empresa no
escritório do brasil e essa semana eles
assinaram minha contratação
a olimpíada aconteceu em 2015 e eu
apliquei esse vídeo sobre a aplicações
médicas e partner é uma das etapas da
olimpíada era poder divulgar esse vídeo
informativo e é incrível notar com a
percepção das pessoas mudavam ao
descobrir os benefícios dessa aplicação
em todas as minhas experiências de
dentro do meu curso dentro da faculdade
eu fui aprendendo cada vez mais e
notando a importância de divulgar para o
público os benefícios dessa tecnologia
incentivar a expandir o uso dela é eu
tomei pra mim como como responsabilidade
também falar sobre isso
a etapa final da olimpíada ela aconteceu
em viena na áustria
eu era a única finalista representante
das américas ea única finalista mulher e
ganhei
a minha maior satisfação foi ao ganhar
foi ver os benefícios dessa aplicação
sendo amplamente divulgados e poder
provar que mulher tem lugar sim na
engenharia e na ciência é eu tomei pra
mim essa responsabilidade de divulgar e
mostrar que nós precisamos tomar
atitudes urgentemente porque as mudanças
climáticas que que nós estamos sentindo
são drásticas
é preciso trocar os combustíveis fósseis
sendo que estão sendo utilizados por
energias limpas ea energia nuclear é uma
energia limpa é uma energia é de alta
densidade é e assegura assim e além
disso eu quis contar pra vocês um pouco
da da minha trajetória porque eu
acredito que cada um de nós tem
capacidades de trazer mudanças positivas
para a nossa sociedade
eu desejo e quero muito que cada um de
vocês tenham se encontrado na área de
vocês ou que se encontrem na área de
vocês como eu me encontrei e que assim
vocês possam ajudar a resolver questões
a resolver problemas que vocês possam
aproveitar as oportunidades não somente
aproveitar todas que se apresentam mas
criar as suas próprias oportunidades de
crescer e aprender e que com isso vocês
possam trazer mudanças positivas para a
sociedade para o mundo para a sua
comunidade porque assim como nuclear faz
a diferença é que eu acredito eu e você
também fazemos a diferença
obrigada a eu esqueci a foto e eu
recebendo pra mim